ouais quand vous faites ça comme ça on
sent quand même un peu la famille
bourgeoise de rennes là quand même
alors on s'est connus nous faut le dire
on s'est connus en 85 c'est vous qui
m'avez fait commencer la télévision est
ce que vous avez fait que pascal josèphe
catherine barma et marie france brière
donc bien chez vous je vous le dis c'est
que vous n'oubliez jamais ce qui au
départ nous aider et puis qui continuent
de travailler avec vous comme catherine
barma bravo alors j'étais président de
tf1
quand il ya eu la privatisation oui bon
aujourd'hui elle 187 voilà aujourd'hui
86 aujourd'hui quand on veut nous
souvenez de ce qui se disait à l'époque
françois léotard qui disait on va
privatiser tf1 et on choisit le mieux
disant culturel
quand vous voyez ce qui est devenu tf1
aujourd'hui est ce que vous pensez pas
qu'il a baisé tout le monde quand même
les otages je vais vous dire deux choses
1 j'étais contre la privatisation tf1
parce qu on a privatisé la chaîne de
tous les français
oui c'est à dire qu'on a vendu à
quelqu'un et que dans le monde il n'y a
pas d'exemple identique c'est bien
qu'ils les télévisions privées à côté
des télévisions publiques
heureusement qu'il y en a mais dans le
monde on a créé des télévisions privées
on n'a pas privatiser une chaîne
publique
là on a privatisé en plus j'avais
remonté elle marchait très bien bon
c'est une grave erreur deuxièmement
mieux disant culturel
quelle rigolade d'autant plus qu'une
chaîne commerciale est là pour faire de
l'audience et moi je leur reproche pas
du tout ils le font très bien comment
les retards nous a raconté des conneries
vous êtes d'accord
à l'époque j'ai dit que c'était une
énorme erreur quand je persiste bien
vous pensez qu'il peut arriver la même
chose à la france d'aujourd'hui
oui voit bien sûr c'est toujours des
choses qui risque d'arriver en a
toujours
on se dit toujours tiens ça coûte cher à
l'état donc c'est payé par la redevance
on va dire aux citoyens français en
période électorale c'est bien vu
la démagogie ou n'allait pas payer ça on
va vous retirez la redevance
les gens vont dire c'est très bien
magnifique bravo et puis on essaiera de
vendre france 2 donc voilà on s'est
retrouvé à france 2 et causé pas mal de
soucis à l'époque de double jeu avec mon
ami laurent baffie oui et alors il ya eu
des problèmes des problèmes de contrat
c'est dans et puis laurent me le disais
tout à l'heure il s'est beaucoup passage
y est il est devenu beaucoup plus mûr
mais bien m'aimer mais je vous demande
pas d'être devenu plus mûr mais laura
laura beaucoup de talents puis en plus
je vais vous dire une chose c'est un
provocateur parce que c'est un être
extrêmement sensible mais tu as vu c'est
l'aspect bravo je te connais on ne la
fait pas à quoi on te blesse pas comme
ça oui alors à l'époque on s'est un peu
artères de temps en temps mais on s'est
heurté jeudi sur est-ce que je peux le
dire les into vrai défi cl d'hier mais
j'espère que je ne me trompe pas je me
souviens à l'époque où j'étais votre
président et vous avez fait une émission
je suis très heureux d émission vous
avez fait à l'époque parce que vous avez
du talent mais on le voit maintenant et
non mais disons le menabe s'est amélioré
et est à l'époque vous étiez très
provocateur bon et jean subissait les
conséquences comme président et j'assume
et un jour la csl m'a dit c'est une
honte c'est scandaleux et vieux monsieur
de la cncl monde y est ce que vous avez
vu la question que qu'il a posé à
patricia caste il est posé une question
qui est des saunas je vous le dire est
ce que tu es mieux par devant par
derrière c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on a
eu des français aussi accrochés sur des
trucs bien il ya le fameux jour où je me
suis levé seul contre vous président
magnéto serge enfin contrats que nous
avions atterrir dit son nous autoriser à
substituer à hardy matin projet définies
d'un commun accord
il appartient donc à monsieur addition
de produire cette émission dont
nous attendons le début de la production
je suis désolé président malgré le
respect que je vous dois vous savez très
bien que c'est faux ce que vous n'êtes
dire je suis désolé mais je ne retire
rien de ce que j'ai dis là est toujours
dire ce que vous voulez me suis dit
c'est le tribunal qui décidera
bah oui très bien mais oui tout à fait
je vais vous voyez vous voyez le climat
de liberté qui règne mais tout à fait et
je vais vous dire une chose c'est vrai
jespere plus à l'époque j'avais beaucoup
de mecs parce que j'étais au chômage et
pas de boulot et je vous tenez tête tout
seul comme ça la grandeur d'âme on peut
le dire maintenant ne pas me ostracisé
pour le restant de mes jours voilà alors
vous et restez au csa pendant six ans en
parlez nous du csa ce quelque 270
personnes ça coûte 200 millions il ya
des magnétoscopes qui tournent jour et
nuit pour enregistrer les programmes
erika rosy ses émissions oui il faut
faire gaffe
est-ce que je suis intervenu souvent en
6 ans n'ont pas trop voulu me le dire
lors jamais la peur dans le même on
avait quand une fois on a été convoqué
dans votre bureau président sont les
places ces pâtisseries président vous
avez fait en été tous les deux convoqués
chez pas quelques rayons l'avait fait
encore et ont été convoqués dans votre
bulle ogier président et puis vous
faites avant on fait ça et il dit ah
vous êtes pas oui c'est vrai mais
c'était à l'époque j'ai des présidents
de chaînes toulousaines absolue nous ne
sommes jamais intervenu à priori quand
des gens disent censure quel sens sur
une censure c'est ce qui se fait avant
n'y a jamais de censure du conseil
supérieur du vieux parce que le monde
est super de logiciels est là pour
protéger la liberté de communication je
vais vous dire une chose et des
présidents de chaînes qui sont venus
voir en les gérant vous devriez voir
télévision qui est une émission qui nous
posent des problèmes dit je ne veux pas
la voir prenez vos responsabilités
c'est les directeurs de chaînes qui sont
responsables nous nous intervenons après
c'est là que nous enregistrons tous les
programmes pour quand je dis nous je n'y
suis plus mais disons le c'est ça et
pour voir ce qui ce qui se passe et voir
si a pas d'infraction à la loi c'est
tout ça va quoi
déjà d'or bourvil ne sommes pas des
gendarmes
dites moi vous pouvez quand même parler
de bilan la signalétique c'est vous la
wii quand il ya des petits trucs orange
oui ben écoutez si pour protéger
précisément les chaînes d'une loi qui
obligerait les chaînes à passer des
programmes dits violents très tard le
soir et moi je suis contre et nous
sommes contre nous disons qu'il faut
lutter contre la violence c'est évident
mais mais il faut responsabiliser les
gens vous éteignez la lumière chez vous
ici aussi